celebrated magician David Copperfield
will be back on the stand in a Las Vegas
courtroom this morning Copperfield is
being sued by a British tourist Gavin
Cox says he was seriously injured while
participating in one of Copperfield's
famous tricks in 2013 now the
plaintiff's attorney tells CBS News that
two other women have come forward saying
they were also hurt during the same
illusion Copperfield denies he is at
fault Jamie yuccas is outside the MGM
Grand Resort in Las Vegas where
Copperfield performs Jamie good morning
good morning David Copperfield has been
amazing audiences at the MGM Grand for
more than 20 years but now his world of
illusion is colliding with the tough
reality of a lawsuit not just against
him but also against the hotel where he
performs David Copperfield is likely the
most well known and among the wealthiest
magicians in the world one of his
signature moves making members of his
Las Vegas crowds disappear in an
illusion known as the 13th so let's
let's watch the video
Copperfield was in a Las Vegas courtroom
last week forced to reveal how the trick
works around a dozen participants are
chosen at random stores they're placed
in a cage covered by a curtain that
hovers over the stage in November of
2013 a British tourist named Gavin Cox
was excited to be picked to be part of
the ads what he wanted to do for his
birthday was come to America come to Las
Vegas go to the MGM Grand and see his
idol perform Benedict Morelli is now
representing Cox who says he was
severely injured during the performance
which Morelli's team exposed in court
once the curtain obscures the
participants stagehand swooped in and
lead them by flashlight through a series
of backstage passageways out of the
building then back in where they
reappear in the back of the room they're
rushed around this securities route
often very dark on different surfaces
running very quickly and moving and
making left's and rights and not know
exactly with it going and it's a
accident waiting to happen
according to the complaint Cox slipped
on construction dust and debris in a
dark hallway his lawyer says he suffered
a traumatic brain injury as well as
injuries to his spine and shoulder
he says his medical bills now total 1.3
million dollars
my client was put in a position where he
was doing things that he didn't know he
was going to do and he was injured as a
result you know people don't just trip
and get his engine to see God in courts
Copperfield testified he personally
inspects the passageways 10 minutes
before they do I do
copperfield is no longer performing the
trick but the magician's lawyers claim
55,000 audience members have
participated in it through the years and
no one has been hurt insisting they were
moved along in an orderly fashion they
want to move is that true yes sir okay
but now after hearing about the case
Morelli says two new female participants
have come forward to say they also were
rushed through the passageways and
injured as a result we're going to prove
that everything that they've been saying
about that the participants don't really
run and they're not really rushed and it
is in chaos we're going to disprove that
with another witness Morelli plans to
call both women to the stand this week
can you tell me the injuries that we're
talking about well I know that one of
them had multiple surgeries to her on
[Music]
[Applause]
MGM denies any wrongdoing we did reach
out to David Copperfield's attorneys and
have not heard back Morelli says the two
women testifying are doing so for
justice not for compensation Gail all
right Jamie thank you very much I just
think we need to blame this day chance
you know like when Tony and Patty when
they try to lead us in a dark place Noir
and John do not go yeah dad things can
happen I mean I just my mind is like
like that magic is not real magic they
don't realize it's a piano sorry they
told us that they just walk them out the
back
you walk them out the back door with
some flashlights okay all right we will
of course keep following that story we
will not follow Tony and Patty and they
take us down the dark place
thank you again Jaime